einem forschungsteam aus frankfurt ist
in sachen kroner forschung offenbar
einen riesenfortschritt gelungen ist
dass endlich die erhoffte erlösung die
forschenden haben es geschafft die
vermehrung von corona viren zu stoppen
dieser erfolg gelang durch die anwendung
von medikamenten die bereits eingesetzt
werden also bringen uns diese oder
ähnliche wirkstoffe also den lange
ersehnten durchbruch im kampf gegen die
korona pandemie klicks und future bis
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst er nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum gibt es übrigens jetzt auch als
podcast auf die ohren für unterwegs die
links dazu sind hier und ami und in der
video beschreibung
ja das könnte eine völlig neue strategie
gegen coop 19 sein
die rede ist von insgesamt fünf
krebsmedikamenten die die produktion der
viralen rna in den zellen hemmen und
somit die vermehrung des corona virus
verhindern
ein deutsches forschungsteam sorgt jetzt
mit dieser entdeckung für aufregung den
forschenden von der goethe universität
frankfurt und dem universitätsklinikum
frankfurt geht es damit eine echte
sensation gelungen denn damit hat es zum
ersten mal überhaupt geklappt die
molekularen signalwege von befallenen
zellen und deren veränderungen durch das
corona virus saß kopf zwei zu beobachten
und da sind sich die fachleute einig
genau das könnte ein komplett neuer
ansatzpunkt sein um das virus effektiv
zu bekämpfen
der riesige vorteile die diese neue
entdeckung mit sich bringt die
hemmstoffe die in diesen fünf
krebsmedikamenten da werden sie nämlich
bisher eingesetzt wirken sind bereits
erprobt und zum teil auch schon
zugelassen
bislang natürlich aber lediglich für die
behandlung von krebs patientinnen und
patienten und das ist ein entscheidender
pluspunkt denn die korona pandemie hat
die welt immer fest im griff und wenn
sich die zahlen so weiterentwickeln und
das geschieht ja exponentiell wenn nicht
reagiert wird oder reagiert werden kann
dann könnte diese pandemie die spanische
grippe übertreffen vor allem in armen
ländern fehlen oft die logistischen und
finanziellen mittel die pandemie
einzudämmen
die menschen haben keine soziale
sicherung und können nicht auch nur kurz
zu hause bleiben
sprich dort kann sich corona nahezu
ungebremst ausbreiten und nicht zu
vergessen politisch so schlecht geführte
länder wie brasilien oder die usa wo die
täglichen fallzahlen allerdings auf
einem hohen niveau stagnieren
anders allerdings in indien und
argentinien zum beispiel dort schießen
die fallzahlen nahezu ungebremst nach
oben
es ist also absolut nicht einheitlich
manche länder haben die ausbreitung ganz
gut in den griff bekommen in manchen
anderen ländern grassiert die solche auf
einem hohen niveau weiter und in manchen
ländern steigen die zahlen eben nahezu
ungebremst die forschung gibt in diesem
bereich wirklich alles
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die laufen auf hochtouren
die weltgesundheitsorganisation who
zählte ende august 176 impfstoff
projekte die innerhalb von kurzer zeit
angelaufen sind hinzu kommen noch
mindestens sieben weitere projekte die
aber offiziell noch nicht verzeichnet
sind dennoch die expertinnen und
experten vom robert-koch-institut
erwarten erst für anfang des kommenden
jahres einen impfstoff der dann
höchstwahrscheinlich aber auch nicht
direkt für alle von uns verfügbar sein
wird viele fachleute halten es deswegen
für realistischer zeit nahm medikamente
zu finden mit denen bereits infizierte
behandelt werden könnten die europäische
arzneimittelagentur ema zählt derzeit
rund 150 potenzielle cupid 19
behandlungsmittel auf doch auch hier
sind noch einige fragen offen welches
medikament ist für welches
krankheitsstadium von coop 19 passend
welchen nebenwirkungen sind zu
befürchten
die obersten zulassungsbehörde in
deutschland ist das bundesinstitut für
arzneimittel und medizinprodukte
hier wurden bisher 26 klinische
prüfungen in sachen cupid 19 genehmigt
geklärt werden muss bei jedem einzelnen
medikament ob es für die behandlung von
coop 19 geeignet ist selbst dann wenn es
bereits für andere erkrankung erprobt
und zugelassen ist dann geht es außerdem
um die technische qualität die
verträglichkeit und die wirksamkeit
hierbei ist eine sache ganz klar
arzneimittel die bereits gegen eine
andere krankheit zugelassen sind oder
sich zumindest schon in der entwicklung
befinden könnten schneller
umfunktioniert werden als ein medikament
von grund auf neu zu entwickeln
fachleute sprechen vom sogenannten
repeater sehen denn die
arzneimittelentwicklung ist nicht nur
teuer
dann auch extrem langwierig die meisten
medikamente die in sachen gewinnt 19
getestet werden lassen sich nach angaben
des verbandes der forschenden pharma
unternehmen vfa in eine der folgenden
gruppen einteilen zum einen wird an
antiviralen medikamenten geforscht die
ursprünglich gegen ebola grippe saß oder
hiv entwickelt worden waren
ihre aufgabe ist es die vermehrung der
viren zu blockieren oder aber zu
verhindern dass die viren in
lungenzellen eindringen hierzu zählt
auch das medikament mdc wir das mehreren
klinischen studien zufolge die
krankheitsdauer von kogit 19 verkürzen
kann nicht nur in den usa und japan
sondern auch in der eu wurde das
medikament mittlerweile unter bestimmten
bedingungen zugelassen ursprünglich
wurde es mal gegen ebola infektion
entwickelt doch hier hat es nicht die
gewünschte wirkung gezeigt und das ist
übrigens auch einen punkt auch hier in
deutschland sterben deutlich weniger
kranken cupid 19
weil die infektion immer besser
behandelt werden kann zum beispiel weiß
man jetzt das blutverdünner die
überlebenschancen deutlich erhöhen und
die werden bereits eingesetzt dafür
braucht man keine neuzulassung dämpfende
immunmodulatoren stellen die zweite
gruppe da die eigentlich mal gegen
entzündliche darmerkrankungen oder gegen
rheumatoide arthritis entwickelt worden
waren diese könnten die abwehrreaktion
des körpers bei einem extremen lungen
befall dämpfen und so gewährleisten dass
durch diese abwehrreaktion nicht noch
mehr schaden im menschlichen körper
angerichtet wird als durch die währung
selbst bei dem arthritis medikament heft
sarah allerdings gab es erst kürzlich
einen herben rückschlag in der finalen
studie zur behandlung von kogit 9 sind
der pharmakonzern sanofi hatte berichtet
dass sich die behandlung von insgesamt
420 schwer oder kritisch erkrankten
patienten und patientinnen als nicht
erfolgversprechend herausgestellt hatte
somit seien weitere studien für den
einsatz dieses medikaments bei coop 19
erkranken nicht geplant aber auch
medikamente die eigentlich lungen
erkrankte unterstützen sind in diesem
zusammenhang spannend für die forschung
diese sorgen dafür dass die lungen der
patienten und patienten weiterhin eine
ausreichende menge an sauerstoff ins
blut abgeben kann und die vierte gruppe
setzt sich aus herz kreislauf
medikamente zusammen die komplikationen
bei einer kurve 19 erkrankungen
verhindern können entwickelt wurden
diese medikamente um beispielsweise
gegen blut
der insel oder herzrhythmusstörungen
vorzugeben das frankfurter
forschungsteam hat nun einen weiteren
ansatzpunkt aufgespürt und somit auch
möglichen therapie kandidaten die
fachleute haben sich vor allem auf die
molekularen signalwege konzentriert die
das corona virus in den befallenen
zellen auslösen und das aus einem guten
grund dazu heißt es in der aktuellen
studie
denn um wirkstoffe erfolgreich um widmen
zu können ist die kenntnis der
molekularen vorgänge und veränderungen
in der wirtszelle essent zählen denn
schon seit längerer zeit weiß man dass
viren die kommunikationswege ihrer
wirtszellen nutzen und vor allem auch
manipulieren
so können sie ihre eigene vermehrung
antreiben so nahmen die fachleute also
die kommunikation einer befallenen
zellen genauer ins visier
und das äußerst erfolgreich denn so
gelang es ihnen tatsächlich erstmals ein
gesamtbild dieser molekularen signalwege
zu bekommen durch den einsatz klinisch
erprobte krebsmedikamente konnten die
forschenden die virusvermehrung sogar
komplett stoppen
konkret setzen diese wirkstoffe dort an
wo mehrere kommunikationswege der zelle
zusammenlaufen eine herausragende erfolg
für das forschungsteam aus frankfurt
dass sich dieses neuartige verfahren
jetzt auch hat patentieren lassen
in ihren experimenten nutzen die
forschenden menschliche darmzellen diese
zellkulturen infizierten sie dann mit
saas kauf 2 und nahm dann die sogenannte
chromatographie massenspektrometer hilfe
so gelang es den fachleuten die
veränderungen an bestimmten bausteinen
nachzuvollziehen besonders entscheidend
bei der weiterleitung von signalen sind
phosphor gruppen
diese werden in vielen fällen von
proteinen abgespalten oder aber
angehängt es folgt eine signalkaskade
denn die eine veränderung eines proteins
löst die nächste aus so wird das step by
step weitergeleitet häufig hat solch ein
signalweg den zellkern als ziel denn
genau hier werden gene quasi an und
abgeschaltet das ziel des frankfurter
forschungsteams war es das sogenannte
phosphor proteom zu analysieren gemeint
ist damit die gesamtheit aller proteine
die in einer bestimmten momentaufnahme
eine fußballgruppe tragen
das ergebnis ist klar und deutlich und
eine super wichtige erkenntnis für
unseren kampf
die korona pandemie den ergebnissen
dieser aktuellen studie zufolge sind es
vor allem die signalwege der wirtszelle
bei denen ein wachstums signal von außen
in die zelle geleitet wird für das saas
koch 2 virus wichtig diese signalwege
also sind essentiell für das virus in
den experimenten setzen die fachleute
krebsmedikamente ein um genau hier
anzusetzen
diese sorgten vereinfacht gesagt dafür
dass sich das virus nicht mehr vermehren
kann
dazu der biochemiker christian münch der
an der aktuellen studie beteiligt war
die signalwege der wachstumsfaktoren
lassen sich direkt dort blockieren wo
das signal von außerhalb der zelle an
einen signalempfänger einem
wachstumsfaktor rezeptor an bord es gibt
jedoch eine reihe sehr wirksamer mit
aids medikamente die wachstumsfaktoren
signalwege etwas tiefer in der cascade
unterbrechen wodurch die signale von
unterschiedlichen wachstums rezeptoren
blockiert werden fünf dieser wirkstoffe
haben wir an unseren zellen getestet und
alle fünf führten zu einem kompletten
stopp der saas kopf zwei replikation
konkret handelt es sich um die
wirkstoffe mit den bezeichnungen pick di
lisi pippa lee sie pro 51 67 66 lona
farb- und sora philipp sie alle haben
gemeinsam dass sie relativ tief in der
signalkaskade ansätzen genau das führt
dazu dass die aktivierung verschiedener
wachstumsfaktorrezeptor mit ihrer hilfe
blockiert werden kann doch fest steht
auch dass sich diese ergebnisse nicht
gleich eins zu eins auf den menschlichen
organismus übertragen lassen denn die
experimente des frankfurter
forschungsteams wurden bislang lediglich
im labor in vitro durchgeführt und das
an kultivierten zellen ob die
medikamente das auch im menschlichen
körper leisten können ist damit noch
ungewiss denn noch sind die erkenntnisse
wichtig auch bereits andere experimente
hatten in der vergangenheit nahe gelegt
das wären häufiger die signalwege ihrer
menschlichen wirtszellen verändern und
genau das für ihre vermehrung wichtig
ist der beteiligt die virologen richten
betont zudem noch einmal einen weiteren
vorteil
gleichzeitig haben bereits zugelassene
medikamente einen ungeheuren
entwicklungsvorsprung so dass man auf
grundlage unserer ergebnisse und weniger
weiter
momente sehr schnell mit klinischen
studien beginnen könnte
zusammenfassend lässt sich also sagen
dass die fünf eingesetzten
krebsmedikamente die produktion der
viralen rna des viralen erbgutes in den
zellen verhinderte somit wurde auch die
vermehrung des corona virus gestoppt
nach angaben des frankfurter
forschungsteams zeigten die eingesetzten
mittel ihre wirkung auch wenn sie in
konzentrationen eingesetzt worden waren
die auch für den menschen verträglich
sind
das sind also alles sehr sehr
vielversprechende forschungsergebnisse
möglicherweise bietet dieser ansatz also
neue strategien und cupid 19 zu
behandeln und uns im kampf gegen das
koma wie rosa skoff zwei weiter nach
vorne zu bringen
ich wäre wirklich froh wenn corinna
endlich eingedämmt werden könnte aber
trotzdem hat die pandemie auch etwas
ermutigendes es werden in kürzester zeit
so viele neue dinge entdeckt und
entwickelt das ist wirklich absolut
beeindrucken und wir sind jetzt schon
für die nächste pandemie viel besser
gerüstet corona virus wie gefährlich ist
es wirklich das große spezial mit
einfach medizin sehr ausführliches video
mit vielen infos über das virus also
anklicken anschauen und einfach medizin
hier abonnieren toller kanal mit vielen
infos zu gruner und viele mehr also bis
dann bleibt dran